I want to talk about this movie because
there's another controversy besides of
course the flight gate which is American
sniper it made a hundred and five
million dollars over the box off this is
unheard of in January that's what
superheroes usually make a superhero
movies make I'm not surprised Clint
Eastwood's a great filmmaker but somehow
their Twitter war broke out and now we
have to take sides whether the American
sniper is a real hero or not now I said
last week we had kathlynn Kathryn
Bigelow on who had made Hurt Locker and
I said it kind of goes over a lot of the
same territory Hurt Locker made 17
million because it was a little
ambiguous and thoughtful and this one is
just American hero he's a psychopath
patriot and we love him you know I read
some of the quotes from the real Chris
Kyle he said I hate the damn savages
talking about the Iraqis and I've been
fighting and I always will I love
killing bad guys even with the pain I
loved what I was doing
maybe war isn't really fun but I
certainly was enjoying it
I don't know eysan era once said i hate
war is only a soldier who has lived it
can I just don't see this guy in the
same league as eisenhower I'm sorry and
if you're a Christian I know this is a
Christian country I hate the damn
savages I don't give a what happens
that doesn't seem like a Christian thing
to say it's a variation on
there's a lot of anger in this country
and the people who go see this movie are
people who are very angry and this guy
basically says I'm going to fight on
your side and they bite bite for it I
think there's some I bet you if you
looked at a cross-section of the Tea
Party and people who go to see this
movie there's a lot of intersection but
I also think there's always been sort of
a search for the totemic war hero we saw
that with Pat Tillman in a certain
respect we saw that with Jessica Lynch
we saw that in some ways with David
Petraeus as well and when you look
beneath the surface of some of those
narratives it's obviously more
complicated than that I think part of it
also is that and this where you were
talking before he saw the the movie the
interview and there was at some point
Americans want to just do some sort of
patriotic act right and I think in some
ways people who wanted to say who went
to go see this movie of the sort of a
patriotic act and that people wanted to
feel good about this war if you look at
the polls most Americans think this war
wasn't worth fighting it's something
like 70 percent in this movie comes at a
time and that's something we're energy
while the movie yes I did so I went to
go see it last night because I'd heard
I'd heard about I wanted to try to know
what I was talking about I can't believe
you came away with that impression of
the film what I saw was a movie that
treats what veterans and soldiers go
through in a way that was subtle it was
not just about war it was about TSD it
was about what what the wives of
soldiers go through and by the way the
savages he's talking about okay aren't
ordinary Iraqis the savages are al-qaeda
killers who put drills into children to
an okay you know what when he was
sitting up there and looking 200 yards
away he didn't know that's who he was
shooting in the first scene he's about
to shoot a kid yeah but I would say you
can't you can't sum up a man by one
quote taken out of context you don't
know how he said then and I think if you
fight more I bet you say a lot of
up in the middle of it well that
was Africa's or when he wrote a book I
but you've also you've been thinking
what I'm just saying you know the idea
that Americans cannot see any ambiguity
that somebody has to either be pure hero
or pure traitor is ridiculous it's not
that bit in fairness every
like that no the Americans are not I
mean there's not a lot of subtlety in
the lives of ordinary people they you
know it's a struggle and that's what
this is about what George Bush said I
don't do new ones I thought you wanted
to run against him I think they I did
but it didn't work out so well maybe I
shouldn't have done any myself but I
mean it's also very Clint Eastwood right
I mean that's that's right black and
white sort of cowboys and Indians and
it's just never like it's anyone who
watches it honestly it's not a
black-and-white film it is an honest
film about about war and about one
particular soldier's experience and
people should watch it before they
condemn it as some kind of movie we're
not at only for Yahoo's we're not
condemning it and I was making a point
that the real Chris Kyle is different
than the movie Chris Kyle you're right
there's more ambiguity in the movie than
the book